The joe rogan experience.
What do you think about these old banning bossy,
retarded.
Stupid.
It's never going to work,
but to me it makes me angry.
It makes me angry that you're pretending that someone's feelings are hurt
because you have the word bossy.
Bossy means leadership.
It doesn't like,
I have a few naces and I want to say which of them.
One of them's bit bossy and what I mean bossy.
It's not like she goes,
okay,
you sit over here,
we're playing this game.
She's like,
don't touch that.
That's my toy.
She's just a bit of a cunt.
Yeah,
they don't like Conti.
So they're trying to get rid of Bossy,
which is a substitute for country.
They're trying to remove themselves from criticism.
Nobody was coming up with that.
They're either trying to silence free speech or they're trying to remove what
they think is criticism and they faced many times and it's,
you know,
a lot of them.
Like what?
Where's it coming from?
Most likely feminists and well,
what are a lot of feminists?
A lot of feminists are very strong women who like being able to tell people what
the fuck to do and what,
what would be a criticism of that?
Well,
she's a cunt.
She's Conti,
she's bossy.
Those are there.
They're all in line with what's what people don't like.
I will ban Bossy,
get the fuck out.
Famous face you campaign.
But it's the dumbest fucking thing
on their advert or the program.
The woman was there going,
do you know that men earn 99% of the world's property?
Right.
And I,
and then I,
I thought about,
do you know 95% of the homeless are also men.
There's plenty of Bossy bitches kicking cans out of the houses are living,
rent free,
are nice guy.
All you ban Bossy,
you won't get women that are heads of corporations.
Most bossy women that I've known in my life don't have jobs.
Yeah.
And probably would never get to the head of a corporation because that requires
a lot of people skills.
It's not like they've been held back,
bicycling,
Bossy,
I'm there paying the rent and they still fucking bossing me around.
You know,
it doesn't feel like,
yeah,
no,
the idea is ridiculous.
The idea that all these women want to have fucking want to be the head of
corporations is ridiculous too.
A lot of women don't want those jobs either.
They're not working towards those jobs.
The idea that they're completely banned from those jobs.
There are women out there who run corporations.
Is it fair?
I'm not saying it is,
but there's a lot of shit that's not fair,
but life isn't it?
Well there's a good chance we'll have a female president next or soon as
possible.
There's just very different characteristics that men have and women have is very
different personalities,
almost inherent to having testosterone and a dick that you don't have.
Also with the woman,
and this is nothing against women when they have a kid.
I'm not saying cause they take nine months out of the workplace,
although it's probably a problem,
but I didn't give a fuck.
When they have a kid,
their mind does change a little bit.
They become less career driven for a lot of them.
Not all of them,
but they do start going,
I want to spend time with this and Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
And then a man has to step up a little bit more and work a bit.
Huh.
I sometimes the garage,
the amount I have to go on the road and be away from my kids.
So I was,
I can support the family.
You know,
I feel like I miss out on something there.
I'd rather be home all the time with him.
Right.
I know exactly what you mean.
Yeah.
Um,
I think everyone has a role and that everyone's role is different depending on
the relationship,
depending on where you are in life,
depending on everything.
But the idea that it would should be even for men and women is ridiculous.
The idea that anything should be even as ridiculous.
Yeah.
The only thing you should ask is for no discrimination,
no discrimination,
and that someone will be pro,
they were there,
there'd be promoted based entirely on how well they do what they do.
Like the idea that,
yeah,
but the idea that like there should be an equal amount of men in an equal,
a women in the same position that I don't buy.
That doesn't make any sense to me because there's a lot of jobs that men do
better than women and a lot of jobs that women do better than men.
It's just a fact.
And they've got Beyonce and Congolese arise and who is the other bird that got a
Giulia?
God is on the campaign as well.
And then like Beyonce is day going,
going,
uh,
I'm not bossy,
but I am the boss.
I'm the queen.
What is it with black women and wanting to be the Queen Queen Latifa men.
The coin in the night with men.
Men are always the king.
Black men like this is a lot of fighters that call themselves cane
black.
All white men will call themselves the king of the castle.
I'm the king in my home.
That's a universal mile thing.
We want to be the king.
Black women want to be queens and watch six want to be princesses.
It's true,
right?
They don't even want to be Queens.
The autonomy to child,
the only white chick that wants to be the queen is the queen.
That's probably at right every,
every time you made a girl,
it's a,
I want a bit of a princess because they want to be taken care of and black
chicks are like,
I want to fucking own Yukon.
I'm the,
I'm the queen.
Well that was the thing that black men like the,
there was a big thing they used to say it was that the,
we used to be kings,
you know,
black man used to be kings.
You know,
before we were slaves were king
because in Africa the Isley I little villages and they didn't travel very far.
It was easy to be a king when the population was 10 and it was you and the other
hot and you're like,
I'm Queen [inaudible] or whatever and fucking you go out with your spear and you
think,
oh I'm the king of this little tea.
Cause it's still,
now they've got guys that are driving taxis in the UK.
It was like I'm Prince of Dubai.
Bubububuh right.
And you're like,
I'm fourth in line for the throne and there's so many fucking kings over there.
That's hilarious.
And it's so true.
If you really stop and think about it like the,
the,
the amount of people that's probably directly in line.
We were talking about and we were talking about being famous,
that you don't want to be the king of a place that's too big.
Yeah.
You know,
like you don't want to be the,
you don't know either had a Rome,
there's too much shit going on.
Even all these other countries should be able to overthrow you too much stress.
Everybody's to kill you all
the time.
But if you're the king of a fucking small village,
like you probably do,
I'm pretty good.
You get all the fish.
Yeah,
you're good.
You got,
you know,
10 wives or whatever the hell you need.
You can get gold wives occasionally you can go over to a guy's house and just
take a goat.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a tribute has to pay.
But if you like to head of England,
God damn is a lot of pressure on you.
Well,
the King Ralph.
Yeah,
that was a good film.
I love it.
You know what I like about King Ralph King Graph is a movie where you know
they've worked backwards.
They've got all right,
this is the prep because you've got with movie ideas,
whenever you go and move your ideas,
you think of just the broad strokes,
so someone's going,
okay,
in American guy is the king of England and he's a Slob and he likes 10 pin
bowling.
All right,
that's what I've got,
and then another guy's gone.
How do we get rid of the royal family?
I'm fuck.
I'm thinking,
all right,
and then what happens?
Gone.
I've got it.
They're all standing in a puddle and get electric.
They're all still at,
they take a photo of the entire or family at once.
[inaudible] standing in a bit of water,
the camera goes,
falls over,
light,
falls into the panel and they all get electric,
electrified.
The death electrified,
electrocuted,
and then obviously they go through all the family.
They can't find a single relative until they find a fat guy from Milwaukee
called Ralph.
I don't know if he was from your walkie.
It sounds like he was king graph.
Okay.